as word of king aerys erratic and
troubling behavior spread throughout the
seven kingdoms Lord Rickard stark
continued to serve his King faithfully
as warden of the north the proud father
of four children his daughter and I
honor was engaged to Robert Baratheon
the young Lord of storms end centuries
of peace between the north and the Iron
Throne ended the day Rhaegar Targaryen
Prince of Dragonstone abducted Lyanna
enraged Brandon Stark rode to King's
Landing demanding the release of his
sister and the death of Rhaegar Aerys
arrested him for treason and called his
father to come to the capital to ransom
him when Lord Rickard complied air is
now utterly mad arrested him for treason
as well
Lord Rickard demanded a trial by combat
Aerys declared fire the champion of
House Targaryen and had Lord Rickard
suspended from the rafters of the throne
room while pyromancers lit ablaze
beneath him as he burned brandon was
brought into the throne room and leather
cord attached to a strangulation device
was wrapped around his neck
Aerys told Brandon his father was a dead
man but there was a chance to save him
a longsword was placed on the floor just
out of Brandon's reach and the more he
struggled to reach it the more the cord
tightened around his throat Brandon
stark strangled himself trying to free
his father who was roasted alive in his
own armor the entire court stored and
what's this atrocity took place so Jaime
Lannister and the Kingsguard among them
the Mad King was reported to have
laughed hysterically as these two noble
men were tortured and brutally killed
before him seeking to rid the world of
all his supposed enemies air is called
for the head of wicked youngest son
Eddard Stark and Leona's betrothed
Robert Baratheon he sent word to Lord
Jon Arryn who'd fostered both young men
in the Eyrie to apprehend them instead
Lord Arryn joined houses Stark and
Baratheon in rebellion Robert vowed to
kill Rhaegar Targaryen and get his
beloved Liana back